i wonder if biden's a patsy
no he's like he i don't know think about
it
he
he's been wanting he wanted to be
president right right but think about
how he's not there you know what i mean
and so the democrats here's what happens
donald trump enacts a bunch of things
that work right the remain the migrant
protection protocols you know uh um
the the policies towards uh immigration
in general right um deportations which
brought jobs back back to like these
chicken plants the tariffs yeah there's
a trade war there were a lot of problems
but we saw auto manufacturing coming
back to michigan things like that the
economy was doing really well and the
democrats are like okay we need to
reverse these things but if we do people
are gonna get pissed and then joe biden
sitting in the corner with his tongue
hanging out
and they're like let's make him
president for a term make him do all
this stuff and you know what they do
they instead of uh would it be crazy if
instead of like him actually being in
the white house they built like a sound
stage across the street just like stuck
him in it that'd be so and then have
everyone be like look he's the president
like a fake white house right
and then and then they start enacting
all these policies that destroy the good
things trump did
and then you know start wars botch
afghanistan punish people who are
anti-war send troops into syria just
really just go and kovid's getting you
know uh the pandemic is not getting any
better the lockdowns are getting worse
and then it all is absorbed by joe biden
who very heroically looks the democrats
in the eyes and says i can be that hero
he the one you deserve the one you need
he's definitely taking one for the
globalist i would say i mean every
single policy and i don't think there
are mistakes i don't think they're
blunders i don't think they're there's
so much money
invested in them i mean everything the
president does is carefully uh reviewed
by a team of people he has a whole bunch
of pr experts down to the tie
down to the to the background every
little thing is carefully curated to
give off a specific image to give off a
specific idea to to manipulate the
general public i don't think a lot of
this is by accident i think they're
going to blame a lot of the bull crap
that they never had the balls to push
through on the senile old man who's not
really there and i don't think biden's
really there i don't think most
presidents really are there except for
for some few instances but for the vast
majority of presidents you could see the
same foreign policy you see the same
financial policy you see the same
policies that over and over again
predominantly screw over the middle and
poor class and only enrich the
billionaire corporate class so so it's
just been the same thing over again just
just keep replacing him just keep just
keep blaming all on him and to me he's
the perfect puppet it's the perfect
situation to rush through jammed through
all the bullcrap that no one even dared
to put a face behind just a few years
ago and then they'll they'll uh they'll
run kamala
no she's very unpopular i mean she's ju
i mean biden's numbers are down
camellias were never up uh like she was
never polling high she never had a
favorable rating the
the
whatever
comma i don't give
so so who then
what do you mean who if it's not gonna
be biden or or or uh kamala i don't
think it's gonna matter at that point i
think we're at some stage where oh no i
think i got an idea trump jr ron as a
democrat yes perfect perfect plan solves
all the problems caitlyn jenner
you know because that worked so well no
andrew yang
in the the forward party
yeah he's selling a book like you don't
don't even you know this guy's 15
minutes are up screw him is it the four
war party or word
okay yeah yeah uh okay so did he even
like announce how different he is like
his major policy changes did he even go
into any of that he's so no he he's just
like you know not left
not right
but what is he looking forward to
like yeah
great great job it's like a it's like an
eight-year-old wrote it you know yeah
like he's okay
going going back to so andrew yang's not
running he's so uncharismatic like he's
he's never going to win well he's trying
to be mayor of new york city yeah good
job
yeah he he did so great he's awful he's
an awful debater he's he's
hey wait hey hey how about this oh big
pandemic right oh all the all the robots
are gonna everything's gonna be
automated you know really everybody's
working from home and then you have all
the frontline workers and everybody in
retail they're not being replaced
nobody's working
well but but they're not being replaced
by by automation and and behind a lot of
that automation are people behind the
scenes
making food and then shoving it in a
hole where you
click a keypad and open a door and go oh
it's magic you know it's that's not how
it works but he's not gonna he's like
getting getting back to uh who's gonna
run who can run for president in 2024
because he's a democrat it will not be
joe biden he it cannot be maybe who
knows they keep pulling them out if this
is
now yeah
they'll get like a wheelchair or
something and they're like here we go
yeah good go them out i mean are they
gonna walk or are they gonna like push
them around like stephen hawking and
just like saying
biden
it won't be a big difference from what's
happening now have you ever
have you guys seen the onion articles
stress of presidency already ages but in
10 years
okay it's not you're you're right about
about kamala's uh
numbers numbers yeah i think they're
they're hovering around like 49 percent
if she was actually out more
people would just she's not she's hiding
she's the most amazing border are ever
you know like she's she's not gonna she
she's so she's unpopular but she's also
not a genuine person and she's not she's
not charismatic at all like there's
there's nothing to her she cackles at
pain and suffering yeah like that's
that's a bad personality right i mean
who doesn't like right
you were suffering you murdered children
in the middle east no
a journalist is like a journalist was
literally like ma'am human traffickers
are abandoning children in rivers
they're dying and children are being
raped
it's like
okay first of all chat while while uh
i'm pontificating here who do you think
could run in 2024 not harris not biden
as a democrat i'm looking at the chat
right now so i'll be able to answer that
question thank you very much it's free
they're saying brandon everyone's saying
brandon right now
that's like the greatest thing ever i i
i'm
it's amazing it's like uh do you see
what scott adams said he said uh a
slogan idea for trump 2024 his
presidency is like
it's basically like trump's slogan being
a joe biden it's perfect and it's more
it's more fun to say people are saying
your mom booker yeah
pelosi
pelosi i mean dianne feinstein maybe
totally 94 right newsom knew something
these nuts
hillary uh lots of brandon's lots of
friends
andrew cuomo aoc
i'm just reading off some of the results
yeah xi jinping
he's already garland
tulsi
a lot of brandon's
joe rogan
knew some a lot of people were saying
knew some um yeah matthew mcconaughey
hunter hunter biden
some people were saying i don't
al gore i don't think knew somebody i
think maybe garcetti
maybe
newsom reminds me of like a generic
movie villain
you know like
yeah i'm not a generic movie villain
like probably like a sub boss not the
final boss
but like the arrogant guy who ends up
you know he reminds me of you know in
iron man 3 there's the guy who's always
chewing gum
that guy
like not in their attitudes in the way
they behave and the smugness and it's
like he's not the big bad boss he's just
like an underling but like a big
underling you know see that this is
you're right he's smug he's definitely
a very smug person and i think that's
why a lot of these
popular
these popular politicians from certain
states
just can't break out
outside of the borders of that state
like say
chris christie chris christie was was
kind of popular in new jersey he goes
out on the national stage and he's a dud
uh
rudy giuliani
america's mayor right like this is this
is guy this guy was like leadership mr
911 and then i stopped talking about and
then he comes yeah exactly but then he
comes out and it's like he and he's
basically just like a know-it-all
new yorker people are also saying
michelle obama
um and oprah yeah but we've already had
a black male president already so i i i
think michelle obama would win i think
she should be good i think she'd get a
massive landslide
now i'm gonna repeat bill burr but like
why because she danced on ellen yes yeah
exactly yeah i think i'm kidding she
she's she's obama 2.0 and she's a woman
and she's going to get all the way
they're going to vote for she's going to
get all of the social justice vote plus
there's gonna be a lot of people who are
like obama
i think oprah two also has a big chance
because she kind of tested the waters
there were some news articles suggesting
that she might run for some kind of
office and they were kind of testing it
because pollsters usually do that they
usually they usually kind of put out
their candidates saying they might run
and they kind of feel to test this oprah
also had a lot of meetings with
bloomberg with the rockefellers with mr
bill gates when they had their secret
meeting in new york city talking about
population reduction a few years ago so
she's in the inner circle of a lot of
ruling elites she's in the inner circle
of like the kissingers the the
rockefellers watch childs the gates's
they all met privately they all had
their secret meetings look up the
meeting that happened the media called
this the meeting of the superheroes and
this was a meeting that happened in new
york city and they talked about
literally population reduction and this
was about five to seven years ago and uh
a lot of people you know forget how
involved oprah actually is in our
political spectrum especially with the
money that she donates especially with
the culture remember when she was
pro-iraq war yeah and there was like
some guest was like i just don't think
that we should invade iraq and then she
was like what you believe we should be
weak yeah i was like what holy freaking
cow i mean and she's perfect she she
knows how to cater to an audience she
knows how to read scripts she knows how
to push the globalist propaganda more
than anyone else she knows how to hold a
conversation how to debate people how to
argue with people she would be i i mean
i'm calling it oprah 2024
uh i i i wouldn't be surprised not to
see it at some point or some kind of
level of because i mean we had donald
trump he was a reality tv star i don't
think we're going to go away from this
kind of factor of entertainment and
societal
impact being involved in politics i
think it's only going to increase as it
did in idiocracy but how smart do you
think she is on
on policy
intelligence really i mean she she's
she's a smart woman obviously yeah yeah
i mean she's
what is she she's a billionaire she's a
part of the billionaire club right it
doesn't make you smart but it makes you
she had the right people around her but
i would say that's smart you know so i
say i think she is smart enough and uh
and and i think she definitely has the
connections so i i think there's you
know something to to think about this
you got the money to sell fun too and
her running mate would be the rock
or somebody like you saw the rock
support um newsome in the uh recall
election of course he did well he
supported biden too yeah yeah he came
out anything for money man that's all
it's all that's what it's all about
who would if you had to vote between one
one of these two choices you you had to
vote there's no out oh the rock hands
down the rock or oprah
i would definitely vote for the rock
just because i would never vote for a
woman i want to vote for i would have
voted for her
it's true i want to vote for him wow
sexist i know i'm sorry i'm sorry
everyone sorry to disappoint everyone
there you know luke
no no no no no no i wouldn't there
wouldn't be much difference in any of
them and i just i would just for jump
off no no you're just jumping off of
them no they're they're it's like
highlander they can flip a coin because
it really won't matter because they'll
push the same policies
i'll flip a coin but who would be more
fun to see right
think about this way when oprah is in
office he's going to go you get a cruise
missile then you get a missile and the
rock is going to be like who wants a
hellfire missile so which one is more
fun you know i kind of think the oprah
will be more fun because she's like
everybody gets hellfire missiles
everybody gets medicare
imagine this you know we should we
should make this you know the scene in
iron man when he does the jericho and
the mountain explodes
you an iron man today
yeah yeah yeah always yeah so so when he
does the jericho missile and he wipes
out the whole mountain behind him in the
first movie which needed oprah being
like yeah
that could be her campaign for her
presidency like that's the only ad
she'll need and she'll win my favorite
because of the pro war one of my
favorite memes is that where she's doing
you know like everybody gets the thing
and it's bees yeah
it's like it's like everyone's screaming
and running top top 100 favorite things
in the internet that's that's classic
classic stuff
[Music]
oh my goodness everybody knows what i'm
talking about oh my goodness but most
importantly i still think we're very
long ways away from 2024 i think there's
going to be a lot of surprises a lot of
upheaval a lot of crazy things to come
up before then that will change
everything and we'll change our
viewpoint of exactly how we see politics
well first of all we're going to have
you know the big game changer is going
to be like coveted 23.
that'll be i think the economic big
thing the economic aspect will be more
prevalent to be honest we're going to
have a covid forever we're going to have
like a new cove at every every election
cycle it's going to be perfect well
there's no reason we're playing the
beast you're planning to be a thing yeah
a little bit yeah
and the people are crying
oh yeah and the reaction from the crowd
that's
that's what makes that that yeah it's
amazing everybody's freaking out
there's a woman crying
i'd i would do that than go for through
another four years of joe biden like
you know you stunned by thousands of
bees
you have a choice you have to open a box
full of bees in your bedroom or former
each of joe biden well well there's also
speaking of bees there's also an and
memes there's also the nicholas cage
meme
where he's where he's he's got the thing
and you know from uh the the wicker man
yeah the wicked uh and and he's and he
screwed up
like i would rather do that than go
through another four years of joe biden
uh probably but you know the problems
the democrats had in the last cycle too
is they don't have anyone
and i think this is the biggest
indicator the democrats and the left are
completely not cool and see and and the
the list that that uh that luke was
reading you know he was saying you know
booker like no
book booker
booker was terrible in the debates
and he's not charismatic either you know
you know the interesting thing is i
don't know if cool is the right word
described trump but uh there's something
he has an factor right right right
absolutely there's something about
there's something about him like first
of all he's funny and we all know that
whether you hate his policies like oh
it's like when when he was talking about
the definition of what woke is
you know
which i'm not going to repeat here but
that was hilarious it was so funny it
was so funny when he was saying i i know
the moment you won
it's when megan kelly said you know you
insulted rosie o'donnell
oh no you you called women fat pigs only
they weren't supposed to you have to see
you have to watch this shane gillis
thing i'm telling you it's really funny
he points out
uh that
those debates the republican debates
they were electric
they were they were absolutely they were
must see tv because there's there's just
something about like if gillis points
out he's like you know you have like a
policy guy like blah blah blah you know
i i like schools and this and that and
trump's just like
insulting people left and right you're
just like yeah do it man it's like you
know shut up nerd
but it's not that it's it's
that anger people felt where it's like
the republicans don't do anything they
waste everyone's time they had power in
2016 1780 they did literally nothing
trump getting in there and insulting
them just felt good
he gets in and he gave it it was like
they hired a guy to go middle give
everybody the middle finger and they
were happy with that
i mean obviously they were they were
happy they wanted a lot more they wanted
a lot of what trump was offering and
with them saying they were satisfied
watching trump give the middle finger to
these people and within a couple weeks
like even i think even before the first
debate
trump was leading in the polls
i think so yeah right like they were
they're like oh well he was really like
no no he wasn't like you you need to
look at the actual like go to go to rcp
you know there was like one week where
ben carson was like leading the polls
and it was by like a fraction and then
then he just kind of sputtered out too
in weirdest housing pick a housing
department pick ever but you know he
there's totally flame out but there's no
there's no democrat personalities that
have any charisma no none no it's
definitely not harris definitely not
biden but because they can't have
charisma
look a name name name name uh a borg
unit with charisma you know what i mean
like they're none they're just cookie
cutter garbage but there are some there
are some like like well bernie's not a
democrat but bernie had there's
something about bernie sanders there's
he has a certain charism even though he
gets old because it's just the same
thing over the billionaires and the
millionaires and you know and you're you
know like you've said in the past he
stopped saying millionaires he became a
millionaire he's like he looked he
started saying it again i wonder if his
bank account went down he's like it's
safe to criticize the millionaires again
i'm not a millionaire anymore but
there's there's some there's something
to bernie sanders
and and it's the weirdest thing because
i remember
working in news and covering
uh 2016 and you're just like
like you you thought it was a joke like
nobody ever heard of this guy
right most people you know and you're
you're you're almost like well he's
doing it as a public service he's going
in and he's raising some issues he's
saying hey we can we you know we can get
free college for people we can you know
we can help the middle class we can do
all these things and and you're like
he's he's going to bring up a couple
things they're going to have six debates
and and hillary's gonna win but you have
this guy and he doesn't he knows he's
not gonna win and then it got to his
head then he's like oh man i could win
this i could win i could win it all and
and then he lost because you know
everything's and then he forfeits and
bows down and kisses the ring of power
of hillary clinton
one of my favorite moments is is or one
of the saddest moments is during the the
2016 democrat convention i was there and
i think you were there too when he was
just
you know they had they had special um
noise uh canceling uh subwoofers that
they brought in to cancel out the bernie
people inside of that stadium
and another thing to to really consider
i wanted to comment on that yeah go
ahead so you're mentioning you know uh
you know bernie giving it like selling
out and all the stuff and
when i look at aoc
and a lot of she's she shifted a whole
lot as now this you know as she's trying
to stay in they were gonna they were
gonna take away her district they were
gonna redistrict and get rid of her they
were gonna primary her and then all of a
sudden her she started shifting a little
bit more we just saw pelosi walk up to
her and wave her arms in the air and
c-span and then aoc changes her vote on
the iron dome from no no no no let me i
made a video about this and and if you
really have to zoom in on that footage
she ignored aoc pelosi ignored aoc
pelosi i can't remember the names but
policy was speaking to two other
uh congress people
having a conversation and and she'd
pelosi does that thing with their hands
anyway right
then uh
all these people came like rashida not
rasheeda talib uh pramila jayapal and uh
debbie dingle and asc they all came to
that little area where they're where
pelosi's having this conversation
and aoc is like putting on a show and
she's like putting her hands in her like
she's so sad and pelosi is just
completely focused like she's wearing
blinders she's completely focused
on these two
congress people but but wait this is
this is the best part she looks over for
like a second and keeps talking like she
she does this power move she wasn't
reacting to aoc right yes he did not
change her vote i don't know why she's
pointless aoc changed her vote right
that's what that's what i'm saying but
uh irrelevant the fact is one of the
first things that happened with aoc when
she got elected was all of a sudden her
really strong opinions on palestine
shifted a bit when she was on pbs and
says you know honestly i don't know all
that much and she got roasted by the
left who said you're we're going to see
more of this aoc certainly is a leftist
and a socialist but she's trying to tell
that line she doesn't lose her district
and bernie sanders did the exact same
thing bernie sanders i'll tell you what
my opinion of both of these people are
bernie he's in a gym with this 20 banner
he gets put up for his presidential run
and no one cares no one's ever cared but
all of a sudden he's getting a
groundswell of support
eventually he's famous you know very
quickly all of a sudden he's feeling it
he's feeling it that feeling of of
flying so high
and then bernie realizes the democrats
aren't going to let him go anywhere with
this they're going to shut him down and
he needs to play ball or he'll lose it
all and so bernie said i will play ball
he stops saying the millionaires the
moment see bernie was standing outside
the billionaire's mansion with all of
the people behind him yelling with
pitchforks and he's like i could see the
keyhole the the billionaires and the
billionaires are inside and then they
open the window and say hey bernie you
want to come in absolutely and then he
comes inside goes all of you have to go
home or we're calling the cops that
that's bernie sanders that's aoc yeah
he's a grifter he had some personality
he had some charisma but he totally sold
out on many times
on many instances thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you